yesterday was President Donald Trump's
first address to a joint session of
Congress not called traditionally a
state of the union when it is a new
president giving such an address just
five or six weeks after being
inaugurated but effectively that sort of
speech I'm gonna go through this in
three parts I'll give you my general
impressions we'll talk about Donald
Trump's policy ideas and then I will
talk to you about the accomplishments
that Donald Trump attempted to take
credit for during this speech number one
Trump opening about black history civil
rights anti-semitism obvious pandering
in response to the criticisms that he's
been on the receiving end of for the
last several weeks months and years but
pretty smart I would say to get it on
the record for the future also very
noticeable when Donald Trump decided
that he was giving an applause line
you'd better clap because he was damn
well not continuing until people
applauded definitive applause lines very
clear during this speech a weird reading
obviously Trump is not the best person
at reading it's not tremendous he's not
big ly talented at reading that we
figured out and he sort of couched the
entire thing with this totally farcical
set up about the bad situation that
Trump inherited from Obama and that was
mostly riddled with lies for example
Trump saying he inherited one of the
worst financial recoveries in history or
something like that we have essentially
full unemployment we've got a stock
market that more than doubled under
President Obama we have issues in the
economy of course but just absolutely
misleading to say that it's just a
terrible economy that Trump inherited
quite the opposite Trump talking about
93 million not in the labor force we've
talked about that already a Trump also
talking about how many manufacturing
jobs we lost since the approval of NAFTA
he didn't mention that NAFTA was
approved in 1993 meaning most of NAFTA
has taken place not while President
Obama was president and manufacturing
has been going away partially because of
technology that's going to keep
happening and partially also because
people like Trump have exported jobs
including
Mexico and China how many Republicans
did you get the impression Pat I mean
we're just guessing but a lot of those
Republicans that were clapping deep down
at least some of them have to think that
this is just absolutely and utterly
insane and they're just gonna go along
with it as long as Trump's approval
rating doesn't dip into the 20s they're
gonna bail once it gets bad aren't they
yeah I could see that happening it's
always funny to see half the room
applauding and the other half of the
room staying seated yeah then you have
some crossover like Joe Manchin one of
the more moderate Democrats yes it's a
to put it lightly right he was standing
up quite a bit yeah I did see him
clapping and yes I thought for a second
imagine Trump at 3 a.m. tweeting I did
tremendously well no matter what I said
at least half the room was clapping for
me he did not ultimately send that tweet
though lots of pandering at one point
Trump pointed to a black social worker
who was an invited guest he wants her to
get a great job of course he'll be
cutting funding to the types of programs
that would create the jobs that that
young lady could potentially ultimately
have Trump talked about how great
President Eisenhower was of course
Eisenhower at one point had a top
marginal tax rate on the richest
Americans of 91 percent not exactly what
Donald Trump is talking about and then
for me the most vile moment the most
cringe-worthy moment was when Trump
started pandering over the loss of that
Navy SEAL in Yemen at that botched raid
to Karen Owens the widow of Ryan Owens
she was there and it was some of the
worst political pandering I've seen
touting the intelligence that was
obtained which turns out we really
didn't get very much good intelligence
from that Trump has already attempted to
pass the blame over that the results of
that raid to the generals
totally horrible move we know that Trump
couldn't even be bothered to be in the
Situation Room for that raid we know
that Trump casually approved that raid
over dinner with some of his advisers
and we also know that this was a raid
that President Obama opted not to go on
because he didn't believe that the
potential rewards outweighed the risks
and painful to watch not only because of
the visible agony of Karen Owens but
also because of the just cringe-worthy
pandering I mean I think it's clear that
the yemeni raid was a failure by
any measure because 30 civilians
perished we all even lost one of our own
a Navy SEAL and we didn't even get the
top al Qaeda operative that we were
trying to get so for Trump not even to
be in the Situation Room when this
unfolded and then for him to try to pass
the blame onto his generals and use
these people who are the family members
of victims as props I mean it was it was
really just an example of pandering and
really unfortunate if you think about it
it makes absolutely no sense it's vile
it was crassly manipulative crassly
manipulative okay those are my general
thoughts let's get into some of trumps
ideas policy ideas and the context of
what he's talking about just a lot of
alternative facts which I like to call
lies or distortions Trump talking about
the middle class has been shrinking as
we've exported jobs Trump's one of those
job exporters absolutely no position to
make that claim Trump talking about the
infrastructure spending that he's going
to do okay I actually agree with
infrastructure spending not in the crony
capitalist way that Trump will do it but
since when do Republicans like the idea
of spending a trillion on infrastructure
how were Republicans cheering now for
that when they opposed President Obama
wanting to do it and saying it was a
disaster in the midst of a disastrous
recession when Obama took over
Republicans were voting no on
infrastructure spending which now they
claim will be good for the economy it's
totally incoherent Trump saying the drug
epidemic will stock stop well not with
the war on drugs that Attorney General
Jeff Sessions wants to revive
constructing a wall another policy idea
from Trump just stupid right I mean
it'll take longer to build than Donald
Trump's first term it'll cost over 20
billion most uh many undocumented
immigrants not actually crossing at the
border
Trump claiming that most attackers since
9/11 came from outside the US if you're
talking about terrorism committed in the
US that's flatly untrue I don't know
what semantic game his speech writers
thought he could write there to make
that even remotely true Trump talking
about new vetting procedures for
immigrants and refugees previously those
vetting procedures that were described
by the Trump administration were
identical to what was being done under
President Obama so again not really an
idea Trump's plan to demolish and
destroy Isis I looked at that plan yes
today it's the plan developed and
started to be executed under President
Obama
. just not a trump idea Trump saying
that companies are taxed at one of the
highest rates in the world so Trump
wants to lower the tax rate the tax rate
on paper is irrelevant the question is
what is the effective tax rate and as we
know many huge corporations have major
profits but they pay a zero effective
tax rate because of deductions and
loopholes again not really an idea or I
guess a solution to a problem that
doesn't exist he got to Obamacare repeal
and replace Obamacare so like what's
going on with that Obamacare provisions
increasingly popular with Americans
Trump saying well the solution is to
lower the costs so more people can
afford it but he doesn't want an
individual mandate how do you lower the
cost if you don't cover everybody which
is what gets people in the emergency
room for primary care which makes
insurance for people who do have it more
expensive just incoherent yeah we were
promised to hear him unfold his his plan
for repealing and replacing Obamacare
yeah he spent half of that section just
talking about how Obamacare is bad we
get that that's your point
yes Vaughn from that gets to these
solutions that you have yeah and it was
just typical Republican talking points
healthcare savings accounts choice and
yeah I mean crossing state lines be able
to purchase healthcare across state
lines yep it's more of the same it's
more of the same no real plan and and
again just the solution is lowering the
cost Wow
how insightful he wants to support men
and women of law enforcement
it sounds nice it's not a policy
proposal it's just pandering and then he
touted the biggest defense spending
increase in American history
it sounds patriotic it sounds like it's
gonna be great for safety national
security we spend an insane amount
already on defense we have 50 bases in
Germany alone there's absolutely no
reason to increase defense spending
period and then at the end this had been
sort of controversial because Trump had
made some less than positive comments
about NATO Trump making it clear that he
supports NATO it's not clear he knows
what it is not not clear he knows what
it means to support NATO but he supports
NATO and okay that was one moment when
Democrats clapped accomplishments that
Trump
tried to take credit for during his
first address to a joint session of
Congress this is the best okay
first Trump touted all of those
companies that announced that they're
going to quote invest billions in the US
including carrier and Ford most are
bogus and not policy many of those
decisions predate Trump being elected
many of those decisions were not because
of a great economic environment it was
because Trump called up companies and
said take money take money is not an
economic policy and a lot of those
decisions also are going to lead to
fewer jobs the carrier decision for
example carrier will be taking the money
Trump's giving them and using it to
automate their factory which will over
the long term destroy jobs Trump taking
credit for the stock market gains that
have taken place since November 8th
those are under President Obama
absolutely and totally bogus Trump
touting his hiring freeze on federal
workers which is insane it costs money
it might sound good to trumpets but when
you do a hiring freeze you either pay
overtime to the employees you have which
overtime is much more expensive than
just hiring someone and having them work
under 40 hours a week or you bring in
contractors as I drop my sharpie because
I'm so agitated by this you bring in
contractors who charge more per hour
than w2 employees Trump taking credit
for draining the swamp laughable I mean
just completely untrue
has anyone filled the swamp more than
Trump with everything from establishment
consultants to Wall Street bankers that
he slammed Hillary Clinton for being
associated with and for each new
regulation Trump wants to eliminate -
that's just idiocy that did a haphazard
recommendation like that is not really
policy its idiocy so taking credit for a
lot of things that I'd be pretending I
didn't do and taking credit for lots of
things that have nothing to do with him
yeah but I think a lot of people are
going to chalk this up as a success
because he at least gave the appearance
of someone who is presidential yeah and
he stuck to the teleprompter at least 99
percent I mean he would do some ad
libbing here and there but honestly you
have to kind of think of it as one of
his more finer moments when I got enough
to the part was so low I mean just
people tuning in who may not watch these
things unfold every day if someone saw
him be inaugurated and then
wait a month to see him again they would
think that he's had so many successes
thus far how much growth we've seen in
little Donald over the last five weeks
Trump settings going to stop regulations
that threaten coal miners more jobs are
being created in solar energy than coal
energy coal is a joke it's a dying
industry the world is laughing at us and
Trump is cheering that he's gonna
revitalize coal he bragged about signing
those meaningless orders saying he wants
the Dakota access pipeline and Keystone
XL to proceed that is a recommendation
it's also not an accomplishment and it's
also embarrassing the world is laughing
at us about Trump wanting to build those
pipelines also saying and this was just
funny that the pipelines must be made
with American steel number one the steel
that would be used for those pipelines
has already been purchased so Trump
saying that now wouldn't change anything
but the real hypocrisy is Trump has
built many of his own buildings with
foreign steel I mean just a ludicrous
hypocrite bragging that he got the u.s.
out of TPP absolutely ridiculous TPP was
dead as far as US involvement months
before Trump was inaugurated had nothing
to do with Trump whatsoever also Trump
wants to coordinate strategy to
dismantle drug cartels how about
legalizing marijuana which has been
shown by a number of reports it's been
predicted would actually hurt cartels
more than any of the nonsense that Trump
is proposing and then of course Trump
bragging that he kept his promise and
appointed a justice to the Supreme Court
from the 20 justices that a right wing
right wing think-tank gave him not
exactly something I'd be bragging about
but you know Trump did yes that's the
hours somehow yeah yeah yeah exactly
so you optics you think we're positive
here absolutely a substance no it's
never good with substance when it comes
to Donald Trump I agree with you
substance was absolutely insane if you
came in with embarrassingly low
expectations that most people would have
about this man then maybe on optics he
conveyed some degree of strength pretty
bad send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show